we know that voters prefer to go where
their income is most protected most
welcome hi I'm Matt Welch for recent TV
I'm at Freedom Fest in Las Vegas and I
am with Travis Browne author of how
money walks it's a study of where money
flows go within the United States tell
us a little bit about the whole thing
but we're talking about how taxpayers
have voted with their feet since 1992 or
in the book we started a long time
series of the Internal Revenue Service
numbers the taxpayer data file that
shows where taxpayers have moved between
and among the states over 2 trillion
dollars 43 million Americans generally
the trend is what it tells us from the
past performance is that is that
taxpayers are fleeing high-tax States
and flocking to low-tax States what are
examples of the high tack states that
they're leaving in the lowest tax states
that they're getting too well we're
right here in Las Vegas Clark County
Nevada for freedom fest and that means
it's a great time to talk about all the
California wealth billions of dollars
leaving California as they raise
marginal income taxes in favor going to
Nevada Nevada is one of nine states with
a zero income tax no personal income tax
like Washington like South Dakota like
Texas of course a lot of California
wealth have moved back to places like
Austin Texas we see in the analysis over
all the nine states without a personal
income tax gaining over 150 billion
dollars net of all transfers where the
reverse of that is true california new
york and and illinois high-tax States on
income are losing over 100 billion
dollars how much of the kind of
motivation can you detect in these
numbers I mean are you just assuming
this is why people are moving or are
there is this one of you know 25 factors
we're talking about the actual past
performance as voters have moved there
1040 tax returns what we generally see
our major ships substantial differences
and how a state economy is working the
beautiful thing about the founding
fathers they gave us 50 different
laboratories to apply different policies
to see what has worked and what has not
we know from other archives and other
history that 11 states that once had no
personal income tax that chose to adopt
an income tax later have lost all their
gross state product as a percent of the
national gdp in 11 of 11 cases so here's
an example by studying the past
performance of actual tax payer results
across the entire sample we know that
voters prefer to go where their income
is most protected most welcome so which
zero income tax state do you live in i
wish i lived in zero income tax state
part of my motivation was chasing this
data to find out the facts i'm from the
home state of Missouri where Missouri
were pursuing tax cuts for the first
time in about a hundred years and we
hope to be more competitive many states
around America's heartland are making
major tax cuts Kansas has done a
layman's job of really lowering
self-employment taxes 20 this year
Oklahoma's cut taxes Indiana's cut taxes
Ohio has cut taxes west concen has cut
taxes North Carolina is trying to do the
same many states and their governors are
trying to make their state more
competitive so that taxpayers can keep
more in every paycheck all right thank
you very much Travis Browne that's how
money walks for recent TV I am Matt
Welch
you